This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一档 I-Heart 播客节目。保证全由真人制作。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你可以与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士在这里交流。有多少男人带着盔甲出行。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，收听《艰难抉择》。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
欢迎在 AHA 广播应用、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023 年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吧？我伪造了一次检测报告。互联网侦探们动用了大量人力，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这是当电梯旁有楼梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the podcast. Welcome back to a new episode, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, I am so stoked to have you here for perhaps my most highly requested podcast episode of all time. Every week I receive so many DMs from people who have had their hearts,
相信你的闺蜜。在 Iheart radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个与你一起探讨我们在二十多岁时所经历的重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到本期播客。欢迎收听新的一期节目，新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，我都非常高兴你能来到这里，收听这期可以说是创下我节目史上最高呼声的播客。每周我都会收到许多私信，发信人都是那些心碎得
absolutely shattered, who have been through the worst breakup of their life. who are grieving the end of a relationship. And today we're going to tackle all of it. We're going to discuss the nitty-gritty science and research and psychology behind our brains and our bodies and our emotions during a breakup. Why they leave such lasting emotional scars and how we can essentially move on and really begin to realize. the best versions of ourselves in the midst of heartache.
彻底粉碎、经历过人生中最糟糕的分手、正在为一段关系的结束而悲伤的人。今天我们将全面探讨这些问题。我们将探讨分手期间，我们的大脑、身体和情绪背后的核心科学、研究和心理学。为什么它们会留下如此持久的情感伤疤，以及我们如何在心碎的同时，基本上继续前行，并真正开始实现最好的自己。
On a personal note, those who have listened to this show for a while will know that this podcast emerged from the ruins of a relationship, one that I had in my early 20s. And this show, this podcast, all that it's become, it was kind of my savior, my little passion project, that got me through a rough time and allowed me to really reclaim a lot of my identity and my independence. And that very ex actually came on the show a few months back,
顺便说一句，听了这个节目一段时间的听友会知道，这个播客是从一段关系的废墟中诞生的，那是我二十出头时经历的一段感情。而这个节目、这个播客以及它所变成的一切，可以说是我的救命稻草，是我的一个小爱好，它陪我度过了艰难的时期，让我真正找回了许多自我认同和独立性。而那个前任其实几个月前也来过节目，
but right as I was beginning to heal from that breakup, I started seeing someone else. I can safely say it was never very serious in the way that my previous relationship was. I never really dreamed of marrying this person and, you know, God forbid having children with him, let alone a lease or a mortgage. But when it came to an end,
但就在我开始从那次分手中恢复过来的时候，我又开始和别人约会了。我可以自信地说，这段感情从来不像我之前的关系那样严肃。我从来没有真正梦想过和这个人结婚，你知道的，老天保佑还要和他生孩子，更不用说一起租房或背房贷了。但当它走向终点时，
And it crushed me. It destroyed me in a way that for the last eight to ten months, I really never thought I was going to recover from. It's really funny how our brains take these intense romantic experiences and do not let go. And I spent so many weeks and months almost begging my mind to move on, to stop obsessing and thinking about all the what-ifs. And then the other day, a flip just kind of switched in my brain. I was driving home from somewhere. I don't really remember where. And for all of my Taylor Swift fans out there, the song Clean came on.
它击垮了我。它以一种在过去八到十个月里我从未想过自己能恢复过来的方式摧毁了我。真的很搞笑，我们的大脑是如何抓住这些强烈的浪漫体验不放的。我花了无数的周和月，几乎是在乞求我的大脑继续前行，不要再去执着和思考那些“如果”了。然后有一天，我脑子里突然像翻转了一个开关。我当时正开车从某地回家。我其实记不清是哪里的路上。对于我所有的泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）粉丝来说，那首歌《Clean》放了起来。
Honestly, number one breakup song. But I just had this weird epiphany where I was like, yeah, I'm ready to move on now. And I'm ready to make this episode. I've read so many books. I've done the research for my own. own sake, I've done the work, been to therapy, consulted all of my friends who would listen. So let's talk about it. And I really want to talk to my fellow 20-something-year-olds who are going through or have gone through the exact same thing. Breakups are hard. They are incredibly
老实说，这是排名第一的分手神曲。但我当时有了一种奇怪的顿悟，我当时想，是的，我现在准备好继续前行了。我也准备好录制这一期节目了。我读了那么多的书。为了我自己，我做过研究，我做过功课，看（过）心理医生，咨询了所有愿意倾听的朋友。所以我们来聊聊这个吧。我真的很想和那些和我一样二十多岁、正在经历或已经经历过同样事情的朋友们聊聊。分手很难。它们极其
confusing and raw and terrible. But they are also such a sacred time, I think, for self-growth and personal development. You know, I don't believe I would be the person I am today without the formative breakups that I've gone through in my 20s. They each have taught me something so unique and completely diverted my life path. It's also such a common pattern of behavior to leave or exit a relationship
令人困惑、撕心裂肺而且糟糕透顶。但它们也是一个如此神圣的时期，我认为，这是为了自我成长和个人发展。你知道的，我不相信如果没有我在二十多岁时经历过的那些塑造自我的分手，我能成为今天的自己。它们每都教会了我一些如此独特的东西，并完全改变了我的人生轨迹。这也是一种非常常见的行为模式，那就是离开或结束一段关系，
and suddenly become like really obsessed with the gym or your work to find that you have more time for your friends and for your family and for yourself. And I believe it's because this experience presents such a pivotal time to realize the best version of yourself, even whilst we're still often hurting and grieving. You know, two complex versions of ourselves, two emotional states, can exist at once.
然后突然变得对健身或工作非常痴迷，你会发现自己有更多的时间留给朋友、家人和自己。我相信这是因为这段经历提供了一个至关重要的时期，让你去实现最好的自己，即使我们当时往往仍然在痛苦和悲伤之中。你知道，我们内心的两个复杂版本、两种情绪状态可以同时存在。
So what I want to do today is break down that complexity and reveal what's really going on neurologically and psychologically when our relationships come to an end. We are going to cover what happens to our brains in the weeks and months following a breakup, why we react the way we do, why the experience is so uniquely painful. We're going to discuss how we can actually apply the stages of grief to the end of relationship and why actually sometimes it's our shorter relationships that can be so much more significant. Of course, we can't talk about breakups without a discussion on heartbreak, but also
所以我今天想做的是，剖析这种复杂性，揭示当我们的感情走向终点时，神经学和心理学层面究竟发生了什么。我们将探讨在分手后的几周和几个月里，我们的大脑会发生什么，为什么我们会有这样的反应，为什么这种经历是如此独特地痛苦。我们将讨论如何将悲伤的各个阶段应用到一段关系的结束中，以及为什么有时其实是我们较短的恋情反而意义更重大。当然，谈到分手，我们就不能不谈心碎，还有
how we can move on and heal. What advice does psychology have for us in those moments when we are so done with the relationship, so ready to move on, but still feel really still. in the past and in the memories of the person and what was. For my heartbroken people out there, for those on the mend, those who are grieving, this episode is for you. I've been there. I know your pain and I want to give you the guidance and the advice that I so wished that I'd had earlier. So without further ado, let's break down the psychology of breakups, the psychology of heartbreak and how to heal, how to flourish, how to let go. I think that heartbreak is a universal experience for those of us in our 20s.
我们如何继续前行并疗愈。在那些我们对一段感情彻底死心、无比渴望继续前行，但内心却依然停留在过去、停留在对那个人的回忆以及曾经的点滴中的时刻，心理学能给我们什么建议？献给所有心碎的人，献给那些正在康复、正在悲伤的人，这期节目是为你们准备的。我经历过。我懂你们的痛苦，我想把那些我当初多么希望自己能早点知道的指导和建议分享给你们。所以，废话不多说，让我们来剖析分手的心理学、心碎的心理学，以及如何疗愈、如何绽放、如何放手。我认为心碎对于我们这些二十多岁的人来说是一种普遍的体验。
We spend this decade dating and figuring out what we like, falling in love, so effortlessly and carelessly believing that these characters are the loves of our lives. And then one day, it's all over. and whether you were the one who ended things or not, both parties are left picking up the pieces. It's an incredibly powerful experience, sometimes life-changing, always memorable. I think evidence of that is how fascinated we are by the end of relationships.
我们在这个十年里约会，摸索我们喜欢什么，轻易而漫不经心地坠入爱河，天真地相信这些角色就是我们一生所爱。然后有一天，这一切都结束了。无论你是那个提出分手的人与否，双方都只能留下来收拾残局。这是一种极其强大的体验，有时甚至能改变一生，而且总是令人难忘。我认为这方面的证据就是我们对感情结束的痴迷程度。
We talk about it all the time, we discuss it with our friends, people write some of the greatest songs of all time on the back of a bad breakup, entire genres of movies and books and televisions is created on the premise of heartache and heartbreak because the emotional and even physical impact is so profound and significant. So what exactly goes on in our brains at the end of a relationship? I think human connection is incredibly beautiful and love.
我们一直在谈论它，我们和朋友讨论它，人们在经历了一次糟糕的分手后写下了史上最伟大的歌曲，整个电影、书籍和电视剧流派都是以心痛和心碎为前提创作的，因为这种情感甚至身体上的冲击是如此深远和重大。那么，当一段感情结束时，我们的大脑究竟发生了什么？我认为人与人之间的连接是极其美丽的，而爱，
Well, that's one of the best feelings out there. someone really argue it's our entire reason for being to be seen by someone else and cared for and understood. Well, not only do I hope that that's been everyone's experience, but it really does change how our brain interprets the world. The saying goes that love is a drug, but it's actually not just a saying. It's very much true. Falling in love releases so many powerful neurotransmitters and chemicals like dopamine, like serotonin, like oxytocin, all of which are really important for pleasure and passion, bonding and other intense feelings. Researchers have found that intense feelings of romantic love affect the brain in the same way as powerful drugs. This
嗯，那是世间最美好的感觉之一。有人甚至会说，被他人看见、关爱和理解，是我们存在的全部意义。好吧，我不仅希望那是每个人的经历，而且它确实改变了我们的大脑诠释世界的方式。俗话说，爱情就像毒品，但实际上这不仅仅是一句俗语。它非常真实。坠入爱河会释放出许多强大的神经递质和化学物质，比如多巴胺、血清素、催产素，所有这些对于快乐、激情、亲密感以及其他强烈的情感都至关重要。研究发现，强烈的浪漫爱情感觉对大脑的影响与强烈的毒品相同。这位
professor, Dr. Helen Fisher, she's an anthropologist and a relationship researcher. She's a She conducted a series of studies on this very interaction between our brain chemistry and the feeling of love. Specifically, she found that the same chemicals, that is massive amounts of dopamine and serotonin, are in play. And many of the same brain pathways and structures are active when we are falling in love as when we are enjoying a cocaine high. And we all know that illegal drugs like cocaine are incredible. addictive and we can logic that love given it activates many of the same neurological reactions is the same you've probably even felt those powerful effects our you know the rose-tinted glasses as we call it that are brought on by this influx and this rush of chemicals in our brain so what happens
教授，海伦·费舍尔（Helen Fisher）博士，她是一位人类学家和恋爱关系研究员。她曾针对我们的大脑化学反应与爱的感觉之间的这种交互作用进行了一系列研究。具体来说，她发现当我们在坠入爱河时，起作用的化学物质是相同的，即大量的多巴胺和血清素；并且许多相同的大脑通路和结构也是活跃的，就像我们在享受可卡因带来的快感时一样。我们都知道像可卡因这样的非法毒品具有令人难以置信的成瘾性，我们可以合乎逻辑地得出结论：爱情既然激活了许多相同的神经反应，那它也是一样的。你可能甚至已经感受到了那些强烈的效应，你知道的，也就是我们所说的，由我们大脑中这些化学物质的涌入和冲刷所带来的有色眼镜。那么当
when that source of our love often our relationship and the validation and the warm, gooey feelings comes to an end. It's a sad reality, you know, we go from talking to that person every day, from celebrating our successes with them and mourning our losses and our failures. You know, we know everything about them. And when that's over, essentially our brain goes into withdrawal.
这种爱的来源——通常是我们的关系、认可以及那种温暖黏腻的感觉——结束时，会发生什么呢？这是一个悲伤的现实，你知道的，我们从每天和那个人聊天，和他们一起庆祝成功、哀悼我们的损失和失败。你知道，我们了解关于他们的一切。当这一切结束时，本质上我们的大脑就会进入戒断状态。
You've spent, you know, the last six months, the last five years, however long it may be, receiving that stimulation and the release of these powerful neurotransmitters and then it drops off and the brain is left scrambling for more trying to re-establish that sense of homeostasis and normalcy. So post-breakup, especially if you go no contact, which I would definitely recommend and we'll talk about that later, but your brain enters basically a state of acute wanting and it makes it really difficult for us to focus on anything other than that person that we're missing. In fact, this relative kind of deficit in the neurotransmitters associated with pleasurable feelings and happiness
你花了，你知道的，过去六个月、过去五年，无论多长时间，去接受这种刺激以及这些强大神经递质的释放，然后它突然中断了，大脑开始争先恐后地想要更多，试图重新建立那种体内平衡和正常状态。因此，在分手后，特别是如果你选择彻底断联（我绝对推荐这样做，我们稍后会讨论），你的大脑基本上会进入一种急性渴求的状态，这使得我们很难专注于除那个我们所思念的人之外的任何事情。事实上，这种与愉悦感和幸福感相关的神经递质的相对缺乏，
but also with that person, it can even give rise to symptoms that resemble clinical depression or withdrawal. And that is the love withdrawal hypothesis. It explains why we find that in the months after a breakup, we just crave this person like they're a drug. We want to call them. For closure or whatever reason you give, we become obsessed and unable to move on, but also willing to do really stupid and wild things. Just as a person who is fighting a drug addiction would do, someone who is a drug addiction would do, someone who is heartbroken, obsesses and craves their ex because they are essentially kicking an addiction
同时也与那个人有关，它甚至会引发类似于临床抑郁症或戒断反应的症状。这就是爱情戒断假说。它解释了为什么在分手后的几个月里，我们就是会像渴望毒品一样渴望这个人。我们想打电话给他们。为了给出一个了结，或者出于你给出的任何理由，我们变得痴迷，无法释怀，甚至愿意去做一些非常愚蠢和疯狂的事情。就像一个与毒瘾抗争的人会做的那样，一个心碎的人会痴迷并渴望他们的前任，因为他们基本上是在戒除
that this person has created for them, a love addiction, a neurochemical addiction. That is one possible theory that kind of explains why breakups are so unpleasant. Even when we know it was the right decision and we are entirely rational that we have no future with this person, that this needed to happen, that doesn't lessen our neurological response. Logic doesn't supersede biology in these instances. That was a huge struggle for me. You know, I mentioned my last breakup and how much it shook me up, but the hardest part of that was knowing, without a doubt, that I could do better,
这个人给他们创造的瘾，一种爱情瘾，一种神经化学瘾。这是一种可能解释为什么分手如此令人痛苦的理论。即使我们知道这是正确的决定，而且我们完全理智地知道自己和这个人没有未来，这件事必须发生，但这并不能减轻我们的神经系统反应。在这些情况下，逻辑无法凌驾于生物学之上。这对我来说是一个巨大的挣扎。你知道的，我提到了我的上一次分手以及它对我造成的巨大打击，但其中最难的部分是毫无疑问地知道我可以做得更好，
but my heart still hurt so deeply because my brain was in the process of healing. and healing an addiction to this other person. This really links with another explanation. I'm just realizing that there are so many cliche phrases about breakups that we're talking about today. It was totally unintentional. But I think it really goes to show how much of our culture and our language is really influenced by this experience. I'm sure we've all heard people talk about the end of a relationship and say how their heart is crushed. heart is broken. We hear people wail and sob and talk about, you know, this almost physical pain that
但我的心依然痛得那么深，因为我的大脑正在经历疗愈的过程，正在疗愈对另一个人的这种瘾。这确实与另一种解释有关。我刚刚意识到，我们今天谈到了这么多关于分手的陈词滥调。这完全是无意的。但我认为这确实表明了我们的文化和语言在多大程度上受到这种经历的影响。我敢肯定，我们都听人说过感情结束时心如刀割、
they're in. You know, you don't really understand that pain until you've been through it. And we often dismiss this level of suffering is overdramatic or exaggerated. But the science shows that getting our heart broken is very much comparable to real physical pain, much like breaking an arm, this pain it's not just in the body, it's also in the mind. And that is especially the case for an emotional pain as profound as detaching from someone we were super attached to. MRI scans on the brain have shown that the withdrawal of romantic love activates the very same parts of the brain, which are triggered when you're in physical pain. similar to the previous study we talked about, these researchers in the US,
心碎欲绝。我们听到人们号啕大哭、啜泣，谈论着他们所处的那种几乎是身体上的痛苦。你知道，在你经历过那种痛苦之前，你并不会真正理解它。我们经常将这种程度的痛苦视为过度戏剧化或夸大其词。但科学表明，心碎确实可以与真正的身体痛苦相媲美，就像骨折一样，这种痛苦不仅存在于身体中，也存在于脑海中。对于像与我们深度依恋的人分离这样深的情感痛苦来说，情况尤其如此。大脑的核磁共振扫描显示，浪漫爱情的戒断会激活与你在经历身体痛苦时被触发的完全相同的大脑部位。类似于我们之前讨论过的研究，美国这些研究人员，
what they did was they showed people pictures of their exes, and then they looked at what areas of the brain lit up compared to when they were shown neutral pictures of their family or their friends. They compared these images of the brain, and what they found was it was really similar to the brain scans and the brain images of people who are undergoing a moderate to a severe amount of physical pain. It revealed that our brain processes emotional pain in the same areas in the same region as physical pain. That's why, although there may not be something causing us an explicit physical injury,
他们所做的是向人们展示他们前任的照片，然后观察当与展示他们的家人或朋友的中性照片相比时，大脑的哪些区域被点亮了。他们比较了这些大脑图像，发现这与正在经历中度到重度身体痛苦的人的大脑扫描图和脑部图像非常相似。这表明，我们的大脑处理情感痛苦的区域与处理身体痛苦的区域是相同的。这就是为什么，尽管可能没有某种东西对我们造成明确的身体伤害，
we still feel the sting of a breakup and the sting of heartbreak mentally, and actually to some extent this experience may even mimic pain in our bodies, physical pain. That may explain that ache in the chest that is often so common, the loss of appetite, the nausea, the fatigue,
我们仍然能在精神上感受到分手的刺痛和心碎的刺痛，而且在某种程度上，这种经历甚至可能模仿我们身体上的痛苦，即身体痛苦。这或许可以解释为什么胸口会出现那种常见的隐隐作痛、食欲不振、恶心、疲劳，
the activation of fight or flight mode right after the end of a relationship. We talk about this reaction quite a bit on the show. Our flight or fight mode is essentially our body's unconscious an automatic response to a perceived threat. When you go through a breakup, especially one that's unexpected, your body may register it as an emergency and go into flight or flight mode or even a state of shock.
以及在感情结束后立即激活的“战斗或逃跑”模式。我们在节目中经常讨论这种反应。我们的“逃跑或战斗”模式本质上是我们身体对感知到的威胁做出的无意识和自动的反应。当你经历分手时，尤其是那种意料之外的分手，你的身体可能会将其登记为紧急情况，并进入“战斗或逃跑”模式，甚至进入休克状态。
Essentially, what our body is doing is adjusting to a perceived threat to our survival. You know, evolutionarily, abandonment by a mate, signified danger. And that instinct is still alive. and still active in our bodies. Being in this state triggers the release of hormones that can prepare our body to deal with a threat or to run to safety. It can also trigger that response that we talked about
本质上，我们的身体在做的是适应对我们生存构成的感知威胁。你知道，从进化角度来看，被伴侣抛弃意味着危险。而这种本能依然存在，并且在我们体内依然活跃。处于这种状态会触发激素的释放，这些激素可以使我们的身体做好应对威胁或逃跑以确保安全的准备。它还可以触发我们之前讨论过的
all of those physical symptoms. So even though the heartbreak, the loss of this person, this partner may be in the mind, our body also feels it. You know, we spend so much time learning this individual investing in the relationship, accepting their support and their validation, building trust, and then suddenly that is gone and we don't know how to cope. We may even question how we'll survive without them. And that triggers this very ancient, physical and
所有那些身体症状。所以，尽管心碎、失去这个人或这个伴侣可能发生在心理上，但我们的身体也能感受到它。你知道的，我们花了很多时间去了解这个人，投入到这段感情中，接受他们的支持和肯定，建立信任，然后突然间这一切都消失了，我们不知道该如何应对。我们甚至可能会质疑没有他们我们该如何生存。这就引发了这种非常古老的、生理和
cognitive reaction. This idea of a loss of investment is another thing I really want to touch on. relationships can be incredibly fulfilling but I think the older we get the later into our 20s even into our 30s or 40s the more we realize that they're also work a really valuable article written by insider said this really perfectly so I have to share when you spend months or years building your life with someone breaking up with them can feel like you've lost all of the emotional energy and the material resources and the time you spent maintaining that partnership. Relationships involve big investments from us, time away from family, big feelings, attention, money. So losing a partner, not through death or anything like that, breaking up with them, it can make you feel as though everything you've put into that relationship was, at the end of the day, wasted. A reaction to this is that we can become quite jaded. This was definitely my experience. I cannot tell you the amount of times that I told my friends I would never date again. After every unsuccessful relationship or
认知的反应。这种“失去投资”的想法是我真的很想触及的另一个点。感情可以非常充实，但我认为我们年龄越大，到了二十多岁的后期，甚至到了三十多岁或四十多岁，我们就越意识到它们也是一种工作。《商业内幕》（Insider）上的一篇极有价值的文章对此进行了完美的诠释，所以我必须分享一下：当你花了几个月或几年时间和某人一起建立生活时，与他们分手会让你觉得你失去了投入到维持这段伴侣关系中的所有情感能量、物质资源和时间。恋爱涉及我们的大量投资，远离家庭的时间、强烈的感受、关注、金钱。因此，失去一个伴侣——不是通过死亡之类的方式，而是与他们分手——会让你觉得你投入到那段感情中的一切，到头来都是浪费。对此的一种反应是，我们可能会变得相当麻木。这绝对是我的经历。我无法告诉你我有多少次告诉我的朋友我再也不会约好了。在每一次不成功的恋爱、
situation or date, I would just almost reinforce this sense to myself that I was going to be happy being alone. And I truly convinced myself of that. But I think deep down, I always knew. that that wasn't true, that I was jaded. We all want someone who was our person. Despite being scared of being hurt again, it was really important for me to realize that my brain had subconsciously learnt this connection between love and trust and hurt through the repetition of these experiences from these relationships that had gone wrong. Or even in some instances for others, just a serious awful breakup can teach us this. It's a theory known as classical conditioning. As humans, we are primed to avoid pain and suffering. So if you've had your heart absolutely shattered, we feel it's necessary to
暧昧或约会之后，我几乎只会向自己强化这种感觉：我单身也会过得很幸福。而且我真的说服了自己。但我认为在内心深处，我一直都知道那不是真的，我是麻木的。我们都想要一个真正属于自己的人。尽管害怕再次受伤，但对我来说非常重要的一点是意识到，通过这些失败恋情经历的不断重复，我的大脑已经潜意识地学会了将爱、信任和痛苦联系在一起。或者对其他人的一些情况来说，只是一次严重糟糕的分手就能教会我们这一点。这是一个被称为“经典条件反射”的理论。作为人类，我们天生倾向于避免痛苦和苦难。因此，如果你曾心碎欲绝，我们就会觉得有必要
avoid or romantic connection as a result because we associate it with being hurt. But that's really no way, I think, to live your life. I think suffering and putting yourself out there, being vulnerable, that brings growth, that brings change. You honestly never know what a relationship is going to do to you and not in a bad way in a way that you never know what new door, new chapter is going to open. You really do have to take the risk and learn the lessons along the way. I saw this really interesting TikTok the other day, and I think it relates really perfectly to this next theory I want to touch on. Essentially, it explained this kind of anecdotal idea or theory around the journey we go through in the months after heartbreak. You know, we travel through this period of grief, then we kind of try and get back out there, date around, have a few unsuccessful experiences, and we hermit.
因此避免浪漫连接，因为我们将它与受伤联系在一起。但这真的不是生活的方式，我认为。我认为承受痛苦并展现自我、保持脆弱，会带来成长，会带来改变。你老实说永远不知道一段感情会带给你什么，不是以不好的方式，而是以一种你永远不知道会打开什么新门、新篇章的方式。你确实必须承担风险，并在这一过程中吸取教训。我前几天看到一个非常有趣的 TikTok 视频，我认为它完美地契合了我想探讨的下一个理论。本质上，它解释了我们在心碎后几个月里所经历的旅程的这种轶事想法或理论。你知道，我们经历了这段悲伤时期，然后我们有点试图重新走出去，随便约会，经历了几次不成功的经历，然后我们就隐居了。
and her theory wasn't wrong. It was kind of spot on. Our journey through a breakup can actually be mapped on to the stages of grief that psychologists typically use to explain our reaction to death or the loss. This psychiatrist, Elizabeth Kubler-Ross, she adapted this theory in the late 60s to talk about the loss incurred by a breakup. Yes, that person is still alive, they're not dead, but the relationship. relationship isn't and I think it sometimes makes it more complicated in my opinion, knowing that that person is still out there, but for whatever reason, you can't be together. I'm going to walk us through each stage. If you're someone who has been broken up with or you're going through a breakup in the last 12 months or so, I want you to listen closely here and see if you can identify yourself in any of these stages. The first one is denial. You know, those first few days after a breakup, you can feel completely normal and fine. And people often come to me and say, I just feel like I'm not emotionally processing this. I literally feel nothing. That is totally valid. It's actually
而且她的理论并没有错。可以说是相当准确。我们在分手过程中的旅程实际上可以映射到心理学家通常用来解释我们对死亡或失去的反应的悲伤阶段。这位精神病学家伊丽莎白·库伯勒-罗斯（Elizabeth Kubler-Ross）在 60 年代末调整了这一理论，用来谈论分手带来的失去。是的，那个人还活着，他们没有死，但是这段感情。关系死了，而且我认为这有时会让事情变得更复杂，在我看来，明知那个人还在那里，但出于某种原因，你们无法在一起。我将带大家了解每个阶段。如果你是一个被分手的人，或者你在过去 12 个月左右经历过分手，我希望你在这里仔细听听，看看你是否能在这些阶段中找到自己的影子。第一个是否定。你知道，分手后的最初几天，你可能会觉得自己完全正常、很好。人们经常来找我并说：“我觉得自己根本没有在情感上处理这件事。我真的什么感觉都没有。”这完全可以理解。这其实
a really normal experience to be thinking, you know, this is the best decision I've ever made. You throw yourself back into socializing, you feel fine. Well, that's probably denial. And it's our brain's way of protecting us from immediate emotional pain by suppressing our reaction until a few days or even weeks have passed. During this stage, our reality has shifted completely. And it can take our mind some time to really adjust to this new reality, these new circumstances. And that's denial. That's where we almost, I haven't really processed what's happened. Life doesn't feel like it's changed much. But for my heartbroken, people out there, we know that that doesn't last long before the anger sets in. Anger is a completely normal reaction to extreme
是一个非常正常的体验，你会想，“你知道的，这是我做过的最好的决定。”你重新投入到社交中，你觉得自己很好。嗯，那可能就是否定。这是我们的大脑通过压抑我们的反应来保护我们免受即时情感痛苦的方式，直到几天甚至几周过去。在这个阶段，我们的现实已经完全改变了。我们的思维可能需要一些时间来真正适应这个新现实、这些新环境。这就是否定。这就是我们几乎，还没有真正处理好发生的事情。生活感觉并没有发生太大变化。但对于所有心碎的人来说，我们知道这不会持续多久，愤怒就会爆发。愤怒是对极端的
emotional discomfort. And it often flows out of us a lot easier than sadness because it's a fairly uncomplicated emotion. Anger, especially combative anger, it also tends to be the first thing we actually feel when we start releasing all those pent-up emotions associated with a breakup. I see this all the time in friends of mine who have broken up with their partners. It always starts really civil, they wish them the best, They say they're fine. And then like three weeks in, you start to hear the anger come through. You know, the statements about how they were such a shit person, how, you know, they never deserved them, all the stories you've never heard before. The floodgates are opening and anger is the first emotion to be released.
情感不适的一种完全正常的反应。它通常比悲伤更容易从我们身上流露出来，因为它是一种相当简单的情感。愤怒，尤其是对抗性的愤怒，往往也是我们在开始释放与分手相关的所有积压情绪时实际感受到的第一件事。我在与伴侣分手的女性朋友身上经常看到这一点。一切总是从非常文明开始，他们祝对方一切顺利，他们说自己很好。然后大约三周后，你开始听到愤怒传过来。你知道，关于对方是多么垃圾的一个人，你知道的，对方从来配不上他们，所有你从未听过的新故事的言论。闸门正在打开，愤怒是要释放的第一种情绪。
I think it's best not to suppress this feeling, but let yourself feel this emotion. You'll get through it, I think, a lot faster if you do. Don't do anything rash, but allow yourself to feel angry. Bargaining, you know, despite how cruel or awful a person was, if we stayed with them for long enough, the chances are that we were attached. And as that attachment is put under pressure by distance, we may find ourselves backsliding and contemplating whether this was the right decision. This is where bargaining enters the breakup equation with thoughts like, you know, if we get back
我认为最好不要压抑这种感觉，而是让自己去感受这种情绪。如果你这样做，你会发现自己度过难关的速度会快得多。不要做出任何鲁莽的举动，但允许自己感到愤怒。讨价还价，你知道的，不管一个人多么残酷或糟糕，如果我们和他们在一起的时间足够长，我们产生依恋的可能性就很大。随着这种依恋因距离而受到压力，我们可能会发现自己开始退缩，并考虑这是否是一个正确的决定。这就是讨价还价进入分手方程式的地方，伴随着这样的想法：“如果我们复合，我保证我会成为一个更好的人”，或者“我去健身，他们就会希望我回来”，讨价还价来自于无助感，它给了我们一种对局势的掌控感。无论你实际上是否是那个结束这段关系的人，有时我们会到达这种感觉，觉得一切都是我们的错，我们想要回去。我们想要改变我们的情感状态。我们不想再经历这种痛苦了。我们可能会回顾我们与那个人的互动，并意识到所有那些我们可能毁掉的错误时刻，认为我们找不到更好的了。你知道，有时我们确实会和这个人复合，但如果你在听这期节目，这种可能性大概不是
together a promise that I'll be a better person or I'll go to the gym, they'll want me back, bargaining comes from a feeling of helplessness and it gives us a perceived sense of control over the situation. Regardless of whether you actually were the one to end the relationship or not, sometimes we get to this point of feeling like everything was our fault and that we want to go back. We want to change our emotional state. We don't want to experience this pain anymore. We might look back at our interactions with that person and realize all the times that maybe we ruin the wrong, think that we can't do better. And you know, sometimes we do get back with this person, but the chances are that if you're listening to this episode, that has not been the
这样的。我前几天为所有处于讨价还价阶段的人和朋友们看到了这句精彩的名言：如果当初你们分手的理由还在，那么你们不应该复合的理由也还在。就像你必须真正把自己置于那种理智的心态中一样，尽管这很难。那段感情没有成功是有原因的，而那个原因就足以成为不考虑与他们复合的充分理由。我想这就是我们进入下一个阶段的地方，也就是抑郁。我有这样一个理论：分手的这个阶段，也就是抑郁阶段，确实是人们在谈论心痛或分手时所想象的场景。那是痛苦。那是凌晨 2 点的泪水，车里漫长的驾驶，分手歌单，等待回信，
case. And I saw this amazing quote the other day for all my people who and my friends who are in the bargaining stage. If there was a reason that you broke up in the first place, there's a reason why you shouldn't get back together. Like you have to really place yourself in that logical state of mind as hard as it is. There was a reason that relationship didn't work and that reason is a strong enough reason to not contemplate getting back together with them. And I think that's where we move on to the next stage, which is depression. I have this theory that this stage of the breakup, the depression stage, is really what people envision when we talk about heartache or we talk about a breakup. It's the misery. It's the 2 AM tears, the long drives in your car, the breakup playlist, waiting for a text
痛苦，所有艰难的事情，所有不同的。困难的情绪。在我们体验处理悲伤的过程中，总会有这样一个时刻：我们所有的情绪、想象力和讨价还价开始放慢脚步，我们开始真正理解我们所处的状态和情况，以及某种程度上我们所面临的现实，那就是这个人不再是你生活的一部分了。而这是你真正必须接受的事情。所以在分手的这个阶段，我认为我们真的开始更丰富地感受到那种现实。当我们开始思考诸如“我还会再见到这个人吗？”或者“如果他们不在我的生活中，我是谁？”“我还会再次体验到爱吗？”所有这些非常存在主义的问题时，我们的境况开始变得清晰得多，而我们的失去也变得更加不可避免。而那种悲伤也在增长。而我认为，真正的苦功和疗愈也就是从那时开始的。在我最近的一次分手中，这太奇怪了。我花了前四个月的时间表现得完全冷酷、完全ok。我就像，哇，这是我做过的最容易的事。我已经完全放下这个了。然后这一切在不到一分钟的时间里就崩溃了。有一天，我能感觉到自己进入了这个阶段，我当时就想，哦，天哪，这就是开始的地方。我认为重要的是要注意，这个阶段的持续时间和强度因人而异，因为我们每个人都有不同的预先存在的依恋风格、气质和个性。
back, the pain, all the hard stuff, all the different. difficult emotions. During our experience of processing grief, there comes a time when all of our emotions and our imaginations and our bargaining begins to slow down and we start to really understand the state and the situation that we're in and kind of what we're faced with, which is that this person is no longer part of your life. And that's something that you really have to accept. So in this stage of the breakup, I think we really start to feel that reality a lot more abundantly. And as we begin to contemplate questions like, will I ever see this person again? Or who am I, if they're not in my life? Will I ever experience love again? All of those really existential
世界上有些人可以轻而易举地与一段感情断绝关系，并且似乎能很快地走出来。如果你像我一样是一个敏感的人，有时这真的会是最难的部分，明知对方已经走出来了，而你还在悲伤并试图处理自己的情绪。这几乎就像是一场比赛。就像谁能以最快的速度走出来，而当你输了的时候，感觉真的很糟糕。这真的让我们怀疑你们所拥有的经历是否是真实的。我向你们保证那是真的，让我这么说吧，如果有人表现得好像已经走出来了，尤其是直接进入了一段新的恋情，我向你保证，我向你保证他们并没有走出来。他们要么在五个月内恢复单身，要么，你知道的，他们将不得不处理他们新恋情中的后果。
questions, our circumstances begin to become a lot more clear and our loss becomes a lot more unavoidable. And that sadness grows. And I think that's when the actual hard work and the healing really begins. In my most recent breakup, it was so strange. I spent like the first four months being totally cool, totally okay. I was like, wow, this is the easiest thing I've ever done. I'm so over this. And then it just all crumbled in like a minute. There was like this one day where this, I just could feel myself entering this stage and I just was like, oh my God, this is where it begins. I think it's important to note that the length and the intenseness of this stage is different for everyone because we each have different pre-existing attachment styles, temperaments and personalities.
这绝不会是一帆风顺的。我约会过的人中，有多少人在我们分手大约两个月后就开始和别人约会，然后大约一年后又像爬一样哭着求复合，这真是惊人的。因为你无法通过打一个响指来撤销一段感情，你只是在用另一个人来分散注意力。如果你没有花时间正确地经历悲伤的阶段，如果你跳过了那些基本的情感工作，你没有接受所发生的事情，也没有完全处理你的情绪
There are people out there who can disconnect from a relationship just like that and who appear to move on really quickly. And if you're a sensitive person like me, sometimes that can really be the hardest part, knowing that the other person has moved on while you're still grieving and trying to process your emotions. It's almost like a competition. Like who can move on the fastest and when you're losing, it just feels really terrible. It really makes us question whether what you had was real. I promised you that it was, let me just say, if someone has appeared to move on, especially straight into a new relationship, I promise you, I promise you that they haven't moved on. And they will be either single in five months or, you know, we'll have to deal with the repercussions in their new relationship.
或那段感情对你的意义。所以基本上最终发生的是，你用另一个人来分散注意力，不去理会那些痛苦的感觉，五个月后，六个月后，你又回到了原点。我想我本质上想说的是，这些人，他们跳过了所有重要的部分，他们没有处理你的情绪，他们没有处理他们自己的情绪，他们只是假设他们已经达到了接受。而接受，当然，是最后的阶段。如果你已经经历了所有其他的阶段，就像这不是一个“通过起点”的情况，
It's not going to be smooth sailing. The amount of people that I have dated who have started seeing someone like two months after we've broken up and then like a year later have like come crawling back is astounding. because you can't undo a relationship with the click of your fingers, you're using someone else as a distraction. And if you haven't taken the time to properly journey through the stages of grief, if you've skipped past that essential emotional work, you haven't accepted what's happened and you haven't fully processed your emotions
你必须经历它，你必须经历这些沟壑。当我们来到接受的境地时，并不是说我们不再想念这个人，我们不再感到痛苦，所有的悲伤和遗憾在这个阶段仍然可以存在。但你也会开始感到平静。你理智地回到了你自己。你接受了“事情就是这样”，它发生是有原因的，它必须要发生，你做了正确的选择，你开始向前看，甚至可能再次约会，但更重要的是，你原谅了自己，因为你现在能够准确地反思
or what that relationship meant to you. So essentially what ends up happening is you use someone else as a distraction from the hard feelings, five months later, six months later, you're back at square one. I think what I'm essentially trying to say is that these individuals, they skip over all the important parts and they don't process your emotions, they don't process their emotions, and they just assume that they've reached acceptance. And acceptance, of course, is the final stage. If you've moved through all those other stages, like this isn't a past go situation,
这段关系，并看看哪里出了问题。在这个阶段，我认为复合是有可能的，但给智者的警告是。我老实说不认为你可以和你的前任做朋友。我不认为在大多数情况下复合会起作用。就像我之前说的，如果你关注我一段时间，你就会知道我做过一期关于《前任可以做朋友吗？》的节目，我的前男友还上了那期节目。让我这么说吧，当时我在那期节目中有一个非常积极的看法，但我们实际上已经不再是朋友了。我一直以为这会是可能的，但实际上要忘记你们曾经对彼此而言是什么，真的很困难。浪漫的吸引力、身体的吸引力可能会消退，但我们的身体和大脑会记住。
you have to go through it, you have to go through the trenches. When we come to a place of acceptance, it's not that we no longer miss the person, that we no longer feel pain, all that sadness and regret can still be present in this phase. But you also start to feel at peace. You rationally come back to yourself. You accept that it is, you know, it is what it is, that it happened for a reason, that it needed to happen, you made the right choice, and you start looking forward and maybe even dating again, but also more importantly, you forgive yourself because you're now able to accurately reflect on the
如果双方不在同一个频段上，这是永远不会奏效的。你需要对自己完全且残忍地诚实。如果哪怕有一丝想要和这个人复合的渴望，你都还没准备好。你还没准备好联系。你还没准备好进行那场寻求了结的对话。
relationship and see what went wrong. At this stage, I think reconciliation is possible, but a warning to the wise. I honestly don't think that you can be friends with your ex. I don't think that reconciliation will work in most cases. And like I said before, if you've been around for a while, you'll know that I did an episode on Can X's Be Friends featuring my ex-boyfriend? Let me just say that at the time I had a really positive outlook in that episode, but we're actually no longer friends. I always thought that it would be possible, but it's actually really hard to forget what you once were to each other. Romantic attraction, physical attraction may fade, but our bodies and our minds, remember.
你还没准备好交谈。我希望这能让大家对我们痛苦的隐藏机制有一些深入的了解，无论你处于哪个阶段，心碎从来都不是一件容易的事。所以如果你听这个是为了获取关于如何继续前行并完全放手的明智心理学智慧，那你可就走运了，因为这正是我接下来要在片刻后谈论的内容。这里有一个残忍、诚实的真相。如果你想在感情结束后真正放手某人，你需要与他们完全断绝联系。继续保持联系很容易，
And if both individuals are not on the same page, it is never going to work. You need to be completely and brutally honest with yourself. If there is even the slightest desire to get back together with this person, you're not ready. You're not ready to reach out. You're not ready for the closer conversation.
你知道的，在事情结束后还互相见面，但我向你保证，这只会延长情感和身体脱离的过程。所有的科学和心理学都表明，分手后的几个月本质上是一个戒断期。你正在试图消除你的大脑对这个人以及他们带给你的感觉的瘾。
You're not ready to talk. I hope this has kind of given you guys a bit of an insight into the hidden mechanisms of our pain, regardless of what stage you're in, heartache is never easy. So if you're listening to this for some sage psychological wisdom on how to move on and fully let go, you are in luck because that is what I want to talk about next in just a moment. There is the brutal, honest truth. If you want to truly let go of someone after the end of a relationship, you need to disconnect from them entirely. It can be really easy to keep touching base,
你们还没准备好交谈。我希望这能让大家对我们痛苦背后的隐藏机制有一些了解，不管你处于哪个阶段，心碎从来都不是一件容易的事。所以，如果你听这个是为了寻求关于如何向前看并彻底放手的明智心理学建议，那你可来对了，因为这正是我接下来要谈的。这里有一个残酷而诚实的真相。如果你想在一段关系结束后真正放下一个人，你需要与他们彻底断绝联系。保持联系可能会非常容易，
you know, seeing each other after things have ended, but I promise you that will only elongate the process of emotional and physical detachment. All of the science and the psychology says that the months after a breakup are in essence a period of withdrawal. You're trying to eliminate your brain's addiction to this person and the feeling that they bring you.
你知道的，在事情结束后见面，但我向你保证，这只会拉长情感和身体上的剥离过程。所有的科学和心理学都表明，分手后的几个月本质上是一个戒断期。你正在努力消除你的大脑对这个人的瘾，以及他们带给你的那种感觉。
but if you keep finding ways to see them, sleeping with them, talking, you give your brain what we call invariable reward or reinforcement, which only promotes the obsession and the difficulty in breaking things off completely. Every time you see your ex, especially in a manner that is reminiscent of your past romantic relationship, your brain receives a dopamine hit and it reinforces that pathway or learned condition. between this person and the warm, fuzzy feelings that we receive. I hate to say it. I know it's not always a popular opinion, but no contact truly is your friend if your aim is to let go,
但如果你一直想方设法去见他们、和他们上床、聊天，你就会给大脑提供我们所谓的“多变奖励”或“强化”，这只会加剧这种执念，让人更加难以彻底断绝联系。每次你看到前任，特别是以那种让你想起过去浪漫恋情的方式，你的大脑就会受到一次多巴胺的刺激，从而强化这种大脑通路，或者说你在当事人与我们感受到的那种温暖、舒适的感觉之间建立的条件反射。我讨厌这么说。我知道这并不总是广受欢迎的观点，但如果你想放手的话，不联系绝对是你的朋友，
if your aim is to move on. From my own personal experience, I know that decision is a lot harder than the easier path of kind of keeping in touch, but I promise you in three months time you will be shanking yourself because it's important to remember that breakups aren't just social, they're not just emotional, they are neurological, and your brain is the basis of your attachment and your obsession with this person. So if you break the habit, you'll find that you'll heal quicker. Block their number and follow them right now. You don't need to see what they're doing. You don't need to see what parties they're attending, what people they're with. It's like scratching an itch.
如果你想继续前进的话。根据我自身的经验，我知道这个决定比保持联系这条更轻松的路径要难得多，但我向你保证，三个月后你会感谢自己的，因为我们要记住，分手不仅仅是社交层面的，也不仅仅是情感层面的，它们是神经学层面的，你的大脑是你对这个人产生依恋和执念的基础。所以，如果你打破这个习惯，你会发现你愈合得更快。现在就屏蔽他们的号码，取消关注他们。你不需要看他们在做什么。你不需要看他们参加了什么派对，和什么人在一起。这就像是去抓挠一个痒处。
feel good, but the sting will only come back stronger later. No contact is your friend, as hard as it may be. We know from research that the end of a relationship causes a plunge in dopamine and serotonin levels, hence why we often enter, I think, a pretty dark state in many ways that kind of mimics even the symptoms of depression. Additionally, I think exposure to our past memories with someone and their images or thoughts of them, it activates some of the very same brain regions that interpret and process physical pain like we talked about before. So how do we minimize these physiological symptoms that often draw us back into connecting with our exes? You need to find a source of dopamine and happiness that has absolutely nothing to do with
感觉很爽，但刺痛感随后只会卷土重来，而且更加强烈。不管有多难，不联系永远是你的朋友。研究表明，一段关系的结束会导致多巴胺和血清素水平骤降，这也是为什么我们往往会陷入一种在许多方面看起来相当黑暗的状态，这种状态甚至有点像抑郁症的症状。此外，我认为接触到我们和某人过去的记忆、他们的照片或对他们的思念，会激活大脑中那些负责解释和处理身体痛苦的区域，就像我们之前讨论过的那样。那么，我们该如何尽量减少这些经常把我们拉回与前任联系的生理症状呢？你需要找到一个多巴胺和幸福感的来源，它与
that person. You need to find a replacement for the deficit that they've left you. You need to find a replacement meant for the deficit that they've left you in. And it's kind of up to you, but I would say something like watching TV or napping. That's a temporary fix. What we want is an activity that creates long-term gratification. One of my friends got super into doing triathlons and rock climbing after she split from her partner. She was honestly so jacked by the end of it. But it was also something that really gave her a sense of purpose and a sense of
那个人完全无关。你需要为他们留下的空缺寻找一个替代品。你需要为他们留下的真空寻找一个替代的寄托。这有点取决于你个人，但我会建议做一些诸如看电视或小睡之类的事。那只是权宜之计。我们想要的是能创造长期满足感的活动。我有个朋友在和伴侣分手后，迷上了铁人三项和攀岩。说实话，到最后她练得一身肌肉。但这确实也赋予了她一种使命感和一种
of self beyond the relationship. Something like joining a sports club, a social sports team, an art class, gardening, miniature trains, you know, honestly, it doesn't really matter. As long as it makes you happy and crucially, you're able to enter a flow state, a state of complete calm and focus and excitement when you're participating. That is what's most important, that you're able to reconnect with yourself, you're able to increase those dopamine levels without needing the other person. But I would also say bonus points
超越这段关系的存在感。比如加入一个运动俱乐部、一个社交运动队、一个艺术班、园艺、微型火车模型，你知道的，老实说，具体是什么并不重要。只要它能让你快乐，最关键的是，当你参与其中时，你能进入心流状态——一种完全平静、专注和兴奋的状态。这才是最重要的，你能重新与自我建立联系，能够在不需要另一个人的情况下提升多巴胺水平。但我还得说，如果能有额外加分的话，
if it involves being able to meet new people and hopefully new friends who have no idea who your ex is, who are not friends with your ex, who only know you as yourself. I think one of the major difficulties moving on from a relationship is how conflated our individual identities become with someone else's.
那就是它能让你结识新的人，并有望结识新朋友，他们完全不知道你的前任是谁，不是你前任的朋友，他们只把你当成你自己。我认为走出一段关系的主要困难之一，就是我们的个人身份与别人的身份纠缠得太深了。
So finding new people, new hobbies, new facets of yourself that have absolutely nothing to do with that other person, it really does help aid your healing journey and reconnect you with your essence, with your personal sense of identity, and with your own self-worth and your own value. A lot of these tips may sound like avoidance or distraction, you know, cutting off your ex completely, diving into your new sport and your new friendships. But there is something really important about just allowing yourself to feel self-pity and to wallow. The people I know who try really hard to pretend like they're all right and move on really quickly, you know, four months later,
所以寻找新的人、新的爱好、自己身上那些与另一个人毫无关系的新侧面，确实有助于辅助你的疗愈之旅，让你重新连接到你的本质、你的个人认同感以及你自己的自尊和价值。其中许多建议听起来可能像是在逃避或转移注意力，比如彻底切断与前任的联系，全身心投入到你的新运动和新友情中。但花点时间让自己感受自怨自艾并沉溺其中，其实有着非常重要的意义。我所认识的那些极力假装自己一切正常、很快就走出来的人，你知道的，四个月后，
they're the ones who suffer the most and who hurt the longest because suppression, which is what they're doing, is an unhealthy coping mechanism and all it does is prolong the inevitable. You need to break down. You need to cry. You need to wish you'd never met them. And swear to your friends, you'll never date again. Trust me, it's a right of passage to really feel your emotions. You know, you don't need to get lost in it.
往往是那些受折磨最深、痛苦最久的人，因为压抑（正是他们所做的那种行为）是一种不健康的应对机制，它唯一的作用就是延长本不可避免的痛苦。你需要崩溃。你需要痛哭。你需要希望能从未遇到过他们。并且向你的朋友发誓，你再也不会约会了。相信我，真正去感受自己的情绪是必经的迷茫期。你知道，你不需要迷失在其中。
It's all with moderation. But I think, importantly, while you're going through this, make sure you create a safe space to really feel what you're feeling. to really, like I said, wallow. I do this thing where every time a relationship ends, I grow to Queensland, which is where I kind of grew up, and it's where I feel most vulnerable. And I know there that I am safe,
这一切都要适度。但我认为，重要的是，当你经历这一切时，一定要创造一个安全的空间，去真实地感受你的所思所感。就像我说的，去尽情沉溺吧。我有一个习惯，每当一段关系结束时，我就会去昆士兰，那里是我长大的地方，也是我感到最脆弱的地方。我知道在那里我是安全的，
that I am able to really express myself, I'm able to feel my emotions, there's no one I need to keep up with, I'm not going to run into them anywhere. And it can be something, as simple as rearranging your room to kind of disassociate from the memories you might have with them in there. Go and buy yourself a cozy breakup blanket or a candle. Create a little oasis for yourself to be vulnerable and to be emotional and give yourself time to endure the pain. I know it's so
我能够真正地表达自己，我能够感受自己的情绪，没有谁需要我去迎合，我也不会在那里碰巧撞见他们。这也可以很简单，比如重新布置你的房间，好让自己从你在那里和他们一起留下的记忆中抽离出来。去给自己买一条舒适的分手毯或一支蜡烛。为自己创造一个小绿洲，去展露脆弱，去释放情感，给自己时间去忍受痛苦。我知道
much easier to distract, to flee, to run away from hard emotions. But I think that you'll be surprised how much you will learn about yourself because emotional release brings clarity. I also think it's really important to give yourself the closure that you need. I think where people often go wrong as they try and move on from someone is believing that only the other person can bring them closure and I don't believe that for a second. Ask yourself if you're thinking about reaching out, if you're thinking about having the closure conversation with them, what exactly are you looking for when you're talking about closure? Is there really a specific thing that they can give you or they can say that's going to make you feel
转移注意力、逃避、躲开痛苦的情绪要容易得多。但我认为你会惊讶于自己对自己的了解会有多深，因为情绪的宣泄会带来清晰的思路。我也觉得，给自己所需要的释怀（closure）真的非常重要。我认为人们在试图走出一段感情时往往会犯的错误，是相信只有另一个人才能带给他们释怀，我一秒钟都不信这个。问问你自己，如果你在考虑联系对方，如果你在考虑和他们进行那场求得释怀的对话，当你谈到释怀时，你到底在寻找什么？他们真的能给你什么具体的东西，或者说出什么话，能让你感觉
better? The answer is probably not. And even if there is, it's very unlikely that they're actually going to say it. Here's the truth. You can give yourself the closure that you need. They are not responsible for healing you. That's your job. And there are a few ways that you can kind of activate that closing of the chapter, ways that you can pursue full body and emotional closure from your previous relationship. The one I always suggest is to write a letter to that person. Just get a couple pieces of paper. I want you to write everything that you loved about them, everything that was special but also why you're mad, why you're angry, while you're miserable. Talk about how you feel right now, but also why you need to let go. Consider it almost a final love letter to them,
好一点吗？答案很可能是不会。退一步说，即使真的有，他们也极不大可能会说出口。这就是真相：你可以自己给自己所需要的释怀。他们不负责治愈你。那是你的工作。有几种方法可以帮你激活这一章节的闭环，让你能够从上一段感情中获得全方位的身心释怀。我一直建议的方法是给那个人写一封信。只需准备几张纸。我希望你写下你爱他们的一切、所有特别的地方，但也要写下为什么你很疯狂、为什么你很生气、为什么你很痛苦。谈谈你现在的感受，但也要谈谈你为什么要放手。把它当作给他们的最后一封情书，
all of the emotions that you're feeling, put it on the page. And then I want you to put it away. And I also don't want you to stop writing until you've really done. You've really exhausted all the thoughts in your brain and either get rid of that letter or keep it in a box. Don't send it to them. Don't tell anyone about it. Just do it for you.
把你所有的情绪都倾注在纸上。然后我希望你把它收起来。我也希望你不要停下笔，直到你真正写完。当你真正把脑海中的所有想法都倾诉殆尽后，要么把那封信扔掉，要么把它收在盒子里。不要发给他们。不要告诉任何人。只为你自己做这件事。
Say goodbye in your own way. I also want you to remove anything that reminds you of them from your physical space. All that's going to do is reactivate those synaptic connections in your brain that make you want them back,
以你自己的方式说再见。我还希望你从你的物理空间中移除任何让你想起他们的东西。那些东西只会重新激活你大脑中那些让你想让他们回来的突触连接，
that make you long and obsess. It's really important to recreate or refurbish or clean your personal spaces of memories of them so that you can reclaim them as your own. If you're really struggling and you're like, I really want to reach out to this person, no contact isn't working, I miss them, they are the love of my life, visualization is your friend. I want you to visualize yourself bearing a box containing all the memories from that relationship. And if that thought comes in where you're like, I can't stop thinking about this person, I can't stop obsessing over them, one of my friends gave me an amazing strategy for this. Imagine their
让你渴望和执着。重新打造、翻新或清理你的个人空间中关于他们的记忆，以此来将这些空间收复为归你所有，这真的非常重要。如果你真的很挣扎，心里想着：我真的好想联系这个人，不联系这一招不管用，我想念他们，他们是我一生的挚爱——那么，可视化（想象法）就是你的朋友。我希望你想象自己在一个盒子里埋葬了来自那段感情的所有记忆。如果那个念头突然闯进来，让你觉得“我无法停止想这个人，我无法停止对他们的执念”，我一个朋友为此给了我一个绝妙的策略。想象他们的
face on a ball and then picture yourself hitting that ball as far away as possible. It really helps. I will say that I have used that a few times. And visualization is a great way of kind of tricking your brain into creating a reality that it wants. I think it's also important, you know, with that letter idea that we suggested to make peace with the past, but accept the future. They're no longer going to be in your life. That's a really hard pill to swallow. But write out all of your favorite things about them on a piece of paper.
脸在一颗球上，然后想象自己把那个球尽可能远地击飞。这真的很有用。我可以说我用过好几次了。可视化是一种极好的方法，可以欺骗你的大脑，让它创造出它想要的现实。我认为这也很重要，你知道，结合我们之前建议的写信的主意，与过去讲和，但要接受未来。他们将不再出现在你的生活中。这是一个很难咽下的现实。但请在一张纸上写下你喜欢他们的所有理由。
And then for each reason, I want you to write down the reasons why you needed to break up. the reasons why you couldn't stay, why this breakup is necessary. Sometimes I think it's important to go deeper into the belly of the beast before we emerge. And remind yourself that there is a better love out there for you and you're willing to wait. There is someone who is going to love you in a way that you cannot even imagine who is going to think that you're the most perfect person, who is going to treat you in a way that you have begged to be treated from every past person. I always say this on the show, so sorry if I'm like a broken record, but I would rather find the love of my life at 35,
然后对于每一个理由，我希望你写下你必须分手的理由。为什么你无法继续留下，为什么这次分手是必要的。有时候我认为，在我们破茧而出之前，深入探索痛苦的深渊是很重要的。提醒自己，外面有更好的爱情在等着你，而你愿意等待。会有一个人以你甚至无法想象的方式爱你，会觉得你是最完美的人，会以你曾在过去的每个人身上苦苦哀求的方式来对待你。我总是在节目里这么说，所以如果我像个复读机一样请见谅，但我宁愿在35岁时找到一生的挚爱，
then reach that age and realize that I'd settled too soon. Also, whatever you do, if you are still emotionally raw, do not get into a new relationship. That is the number one piece of advice. I probably should have said it sooner. I know it can be so easy to use love and affection and the love and affection of another person to soothe the wounds of loss.
也不愿到了那个年龄才意识到自己过早地将就了。另外，无论你做什么，如果你内心仍然满是情感的创伤，就千万不要开始一段新的感情。这是第一号建议。我可能应该早点说出来的。我知道利用爱与情意、利用另一个人的爱与情意来抚平失去的创伤是多么容易。
But I promise you in the long run it will come back to bite you. Take some time to be alone. It's really sacred. There is going to be a point in your future when you're married, when you have kids, whatever, where you're going to look back at this time where you were single in your 20s and wish that you just had one more day like that. So really cherish it. And I promise you will thank yourself.
但我向你保证，从长远来看，这会在日后反噬你。花点时间独自呆一会儿。这真的很神圣。在你的未来，当你结了婚、有了孩子或者无论如何时，总会有一个时刻，你会回想起这段二十多岁单身的时光，然后恨不得能再多过一天这样的日子。所以一定要珍惜它。我向你保证，你会感谢自己的。
You will learn so much about who you are. You will discover so much about your identity and your personality through heartbreak. More than you will in any relationship. more than any relationship can teach you. You know, we've all been there, and I know a few of you will roll your eyes when I say this. I'm sorry, but it does get better. There are people out there who will love you, like I said, more than you ever could anticipate. And the end of one chapter is the beginning of an even better one, even if it takes a while.
你会通过心碎学到很多关于你是谁的知识。通过心碎，你将发现关于你的身份和个性的巨大秘密。这比你在任何关系中学到的都要多，比任何关系能教给你的都要多。你知道，我们都经历过，我也知道当我说这话时，你们当中会有些人翻白眼。对不起，但情况确实会好转的。正如我所说，会有那样的人去爱你们，超越你们所能预期的程度。一个章节的结束就是另一个更好章节的开始，哪怕这需要花上一段时间。
I promise that the growth and the maturity is worth it. So I'm sending love to you all, all my heartbroken people out there. I hope that this episode helped you and that you do not get into a new relationship. I feel like that is the major point that we took away from this episode. But I really didn't love kind of exploring this. You know, like I said, I feel like I've just come out of it and I finally kind of felt ready to really do some of the deep diving. that I'd wish I'd done earlier and to just kind of talk about it because I know it can be really, really difficult.
我向你保证，成长和成熟是值得的。所以我把爱送给你们所有人，所有心碎的人。我希望这一集能帮助到你们，并且你们不会开启新恋情。我觉得这是我们从这一集节目中获得的最主要的要点。但我真的很喜欢探讨这个话题。你知道，就像我说的，我觉得我刚刚从那段阴影中走出来，终于觉得自己准备好进行一些深刻的挖掘了，去挖掘那些我希望自己早点做的事情，并且开诚布公地谈论它，因为我知道这真的、真的很不容易。
So I am sending you love. I'm sending you strength. It will get better. I'm sorry to say it. I know it's annoying, but I promise you it will. And I just want to thank you for following along and listening to this episode. If you enjoyed it, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now.
所以我把爱送给你们。我把力量送给你们。一切都会好起来的。很抱歉这么说。我知道这听起来有点烦人，但我向你保证，它真的会好起来。我只想感谢你们一路以来的关注和收听本期节目。如果你喜欢它，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评。
Follow us on Instagram. If you want to be more involved, if you have to be more involved. any episode suggestions. I love to hear your ideas and it really makes my day to hear that you guys are engaged and that you want to learn more. So we are at that psychology podcast on Instagram. Also, I talked about this in last week's episode, but we now have merchandise available. So if you want to be decked out with some, the psychology of your 20s podcast merchandise, guys, please visit our website or the link in the podcast description and send me a photo. I would love to see you guys wearing your beautiful merch.
在Instagram上关注我们。如果你想更多地参与进来，如果你有什么节目建议的话。我喜欢听你们的想法，听到你们积极参与并且想要了解更多，这让我整个人都精神焕发。所以在Instagram上可以搜索“the psychology podcast”。另外，我在上周的节目中谈到过，我们现在有周边商品出售了。所以如果你想身穿“20岁心理学”播客的周边装备，朋友们，请访问我们的网站或播客简介中的链接，并给我发张照片。我很想看你们穿上精美周边的样子。
And thank you so much for listening. I can't wait to be back next week for another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere. but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
非常感谢你们的收听。我迫不及待地想在下周回到这里带来另一期节目。嘿，各位过得怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难一课》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关注的是黑人的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话。但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套坚硬的盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeart广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难一课》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我伪造了一次测试。”这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉利斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的大脑都炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在iHeart广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。记住是数字2%。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart, Heart.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能就这样逃脱惩罚。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。在iHeart广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜：相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。这是一个iHeart播客。
Podcasts. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。